[Music]
we're here with Tim CTO from tech
Ellucian will be sharing with us a bit
more about tech Ellucian and how they
implement anthos but first Tim can you
tell us a bit more about what tech
Ellucian does and what it means to be a
Google cloud partner sure well first of
all thanks mark for having me on the
show it's great to be here
Tech Ellucian helps companies come in
modernize their application stack and
really come up with a strategy on how to
get to the cloud and then we'll go in
set up their cloud environment for them
make sure it's secure and ready to be
you know start deploying applications to
and then we'll even run manage services
at the end if they're interested I work
with a lot of companies and they really
really want to modernize a place and
they want to run containers and they
want to run in their data center or
maybe multiple cloud providers and with
the options that out there are really
limited and they all have some sort of
drawback and some sort of you know
things that really stop you from working
with it whereas that though it really
doesn't I mean there's a lot of amazing
things with it it's based on open source
technology it's you know frees you from
the vendor lock and you can deploy it to
many clouds it has the power of gke so
it helps you run the cloud for you and
it really is it's not that expensive so
there's just a lot of benefits to it
that makes sense for how anthos can help
people but how does it actually do those
individual things anthos is actually a
collection of tools oh I should say a
collection of mostly open-source tools
which even brings a lot of more power to
it so first you have gke on prem which
brings you the power of gke and you know
all those benefits like I said that
Google brings forward for you you know
manages the clusters for you it allows
you that scalability and all the amazing
things going to come along with it
second you got the emphasis of
configuration management which is a
great piece of technology that allows
you to treat your configurations as code
so you can check them into the
repository and make changes and when you
want to change or update the system and
automatically pull it down the next is
the anthos service mesh which is a
product based on sto which allows you to
kind of get some insight into your inter
process communication between your
containers and get some insight into
actually what's going on next on the
list you have a cloud run which is a
server list technology that allows you
to bring the functions and the you know
the serverless benefits you get to your
data center to a other cloud provider
and then finally you have the
marketplace so if you need to use you
know third-party tools like MongoDB
Retta sore elasticsearch or any of the
things that are actually in the
marketplace or you can bring those to
wherever you're actually one man goes so
it makes sense these different pieces
kind of play together to create a really
great solution for a wide variety of use
cases can you talk a bit more about how
you've implemented anthos in a specific
use case and like what that brought to
the table absolutely anthos is still
relatively - new technology you know it
just came out last April so you know
people are still learning to you know
get their hands around and figure out
how it works so we've been working with
a lot of customers and when they get
embark on this journey by themselves you
know and they don't properly plan and
strategize how they're gonna do this
they kind of run into problems and we've
saved many customers coming in and
helping them strategize so we're able to
come in set up a plan use some of our
automation in our IP that we've created
and helped them get to anthos in 30 days
or less
another good scenario that we worked
with which is very very specific one as
we were working with a client and the IT
operations guy probably had a little too
much power than he should have and he
was you know working with the
environment and he was in a qualen
vironment at least he thought he was in
a quality environment but he was
actually in a production environment and
he accidentally deleted the namespace
and you can't imagine what the
repercussions of that were
so with anthos if he was running anthos
and and that was configuration manager
he wouldn't have had that problem
because if you delete the namespace it
will automatically go back to the single
source of truth aka the repository pull
the latest version of whatever it was
and rebuild a cluster for you so
actually after we deployed anthos for
him we actually showed him this and had
him actually do it and he was amazed at
how quick it actually rebuilt the
cluster right in front I'm sure that's a
situation that unfortunately a lot of us
can relate to fortunately yes but it
kind of gives a good example of where
the power of anthos and implementing it
comes from so for people who are
interested in in maybe taking on anthos
or learning more about it what are some
of the big takeaways for them sure the
biggest thing that I think that you kind
of don't necessarily think about is it
really brings the cloud to you allows
you to modernize in place so if you want
to run containers and micro services and
you want to run that in your data center
or really any cloud provider that you
choose it brings that keep abilities for
you and it brings all the power of gke
and the management of that it's also
great for companies that are have
problems with a there are regulations
whether there be
data regulations or government
regulations where they got to keep all
the data in one place you know you can
bring the cloud to them where you don't
have to get the data out you know some
of the big takeaways that I've you know
learnt from actually setting up and
installing anthos is you know make sure
that you have full logging enabled I
mean you need to be able to see every
log item that goes in whether it's info
or debug you know the more logging you
have the better you'll be and second you
know when you're actually going in and
setting this up you need to be really
good at recreating this you need to be
able to wipe it clean start fresh and
just keep going in and plugging away
it's always great to hear these customer
stories so thank you so much for coming
in and telling us a bit more about what
makes Antho so powerful thanks buck
thanks for having me if you'd like to
learn more about tech Ellucian visit
Tech illusion comm thanks for watching
and stay tuned for more great episodes
of stack chat